[Music]
yo welcome JK news today we are talking
about catcalling is it an effective
thing that works is that conspiracy
corner I think we got we're all in sync
I was like I was here the whole time
when did I discussion happen
so what's the difference between
catcalling and hitting on girls
yeah one is like [ __ ] weird like what
it's like yeah it's like no one has ever
okay and then if you if this is
happening you put in the comments let me
know but I don't know of any case where
someone has called a girl from her their
car and they're like yo mom are you
looking fine where you goin let's go out
tonight and the girls like okay I only
think that his problem was he didn't say
yo mama you lookin [ __ ] fine oh do
you wanna go out tonight I've seen it go
down in Vegas though oh yeah some guys
were like damn and then just the girls
are like okay there's a lot of I don't
know if they were undercover hookers yep
where they go up and they pretend to be
real girls and then like they get up to
the guy's room and then they're like
alright it's a hundred dollars an hour
or whatever how to get hooker vibes we
love playing this game in Vegas you guys
ever play this game you're walking
around the strip and you're like is she
a nice lady or she a hooker it's a great
game I love that game yeah it's the best
thing you can do in Vegas I get paranoid
about talking to hookers in Vegas so I
immediately cuz I know all the loopholes
about what cops can do what they cannot
do what I'm talking to a woman in Vegas
I'm like touch my dick because if
they're a cop they cannot touch your
dick then I can allow the conversation
to that's my pick we're just saying yo
touch my dick that's sexual harassment
well what if they come up to you yeah
they came up to me and they're talking
and she says touch my dick
no all tourists that's like can you tell
me how to get to here yo that's my dick
are you a cop are you a [ __ ] cop she
has a visor on in a Grand Canyon t-shirt
can you tell me how to get to the
Palazzo touch my dick right one time I
think I told this story before but this
couple thought I was a hooker and then
we're like looking for a swinger time
like what think you were a hooker
were you where I get it in retrospect in
retrospect I understand so I was wearing
a tight-ass dress that was like all
sparkly and very short and it was a
bodycon dress I was like 23 24 years old
oh right hooker age yeah very makeup
heels everything the whole nine but my
friends like going to clubs and I
[ __ ] hate clubs I like gambling so
they went to the club and I went to the
craps table alone and so and hookers do
that daddy's a look-in
I didn't know that at the time I was
just like I [ __ ] love playing craps
and no one will go with me so I was
playing craps and this guy with this
with his wife was next to me and we were
all playing we were all like shooting
the [ __ ] everyone's playing and and he
starts handing me chips he's like he's
like oh here put more on that one and
I'm like oh thank you sir okay chips I
was the most naive child oh my god I
don't know why I wouldn't let my child
be me so then we're playing he's
probably passed me a good 250 bucks and
chips you're like what a nice rich guy's
so [ __ ] nice and then his wife is
like is there and we're talking I'm like
what are you guys doing here they're
like oh we're celebrating our 15-year
wedding anniversary so my god chill
chill chill 103 so me talk about kids
and then they're like why don't we
continue this conversation up at our
room were you like you got drinks you
have a craps table in your room the [ __ ]
is like and this woman was giving me
massage and this lady's like
well I know how to lip massage before I
gotta tell steam to do that's a new
technique like after like 2 or 3 times
sounds like a married couple on their
anniversary they're not doing anything
weird I would have thought the same Shay
yeah and they're older they're like way
older like in their 40s and so you went
up you want to know they were like yeah
let's go let's just move it up there and
I was like no I'm good and then they're
like I got a lot more chips where that
came from upstairs and I was like I
gotta go meet my boyfriend what's funny
about that is really wow that is a
hooker with scruples we start getting
low self-esteem like [ __ ] we got denied
by a hooker oh you know what it is Burke
we should have used the cash see the
hookers don't know that you can trade
that in for gas Burt
so I went to Vegas with my college
roommates one time and so this is what I
got mister for a hooker I do have one of
those so uh we went to we had this Vegas
trip because well my roommates sisters
was actually eloping with like some guy
that she was like dating for like a few
months and like my roommate was she's
having a real hard time about it so I
think she got drunk at a club and then
another roommate was trying to console
her but she put her phone down and then
that phone got stolen and so he went on
a huge hunt to find the stolen phone and
as we were walking down the strip like
some guy would I go over and actually
like grope like my friend's ass and then
she was like [ __ ] off [ __ ] you better
not [ __ ] touch my [ __ ] ass and
it's like damn chill Ilana like you
[ __ ] hot and she's like [ __ ] off dude
I meant like she was so [ __ ] pissed
because she was just trying to find her
phone and all like yeah then she's smart
wait does she bend over to look for the
phone and he went oh no we were just
like literally walking and then he just
came over and he just like grabbed her
edge
and then as we were passing by and
they're like she was walking she like
can't believe it didn't work what's
greater he'd surprise he's like why was
she so bad she didn't like that Massa
Lipton was I do soft should I grab it
harder harder bells are probably I think
it's funny all of this happens in Vegas
so I used to live in Vegas how many
years I only lived I couldn't even last
year I was there for about nine months
so I moved out to Vegas and I okay
prior to that I went to a car show like
a live show when I lived in Virginia for
this band I will not say the name of the
band but I for some reason become
Facebook friends with the lead singer
this was like back in the day when
everyone was just adding everyone he had
like 5,000 Facebook friends and I was
like Google I'm friends at the lead
singer on Facebook so I'm at the band
yeah and like when I so at one point I
don't know how it happens but when I
lived in Vegas he randomly hits me up on
Facebook he's like y'all I'm doing a
show out there I would love to bring you
backstage and just chill and [ __ ] and
I'm like 22 and super and I'm like oh I
like the word groupie and what happens
to groupies just completely out oh my
god no your guests of the band yeah VIP
smoke friends were actual friends we're
gonna have conversation yeah so like
Dave the show I went and had lunch with
him I still remember another guy in the
band was just looking at me like oh god
you're gonna get [ __ ] herpes or
something like like he knew what's that
look is it what is it every word that
came out of my mouth he was huh and so I
hung out with him the daytime we go to
the show I'm like backstage I got to
like watch the vid perform side stage
and this is like actually at the time
kind of one of my favorite bands and
like I feel all important and I remember
I wear this stupid dress it's the best
thing I could describe it it was [ __ ]
stupid stupid dress has a big flower on
the tours I have one of those I don't
know but it was like sparkly it was
something from like Deb or like
Dillard's I don't know it was just
so ugly so then later tonight he's like
alright we're just gonna go back to the
hotel and drink with the boys and [ __ ]
and I was like oh I'm gonna be hanging
out with the band and so we get back to
the hotel and he's like alright well I
just need to go drop my backpack off in
my room upstairs so let's go and I was
like okay so we're in the elevator in as
soon as the doors shut he just lunges on
me and like just tries to start kissing
me and I'm like we go upstairs and then
we get to the hotel room and we're
saying right outside the room he was
like watching us come on in mama and I
was like I'm good dude hey guys I just
just come on step in he was like is
beautiful this guy was like on drugs my
dumb ass there's plenty of room over
there and so I literally sit in a chair
I sit in a chair and he like drops his
back you're like so we're gonna do order
room service and watch shows he just
comes up and he's like absolutely not
and so like lip lick I'm like fighting
this man to get off of me I'm like no
and then I'm like dude I'm good I'm like
please I was like let's just go down and
chill with everyone and like drink or
whatever and he was like what's wrong do
it
do I gotta pay you or a Dooney money and
I was like oh my [ __ ] god and I left
like never talk to him again until just
like last year I saw by me he looks like
this woman is like not even conscious
she was I was like oh he was like
somebody tried to pay me for sex and
after so then he does that whole thing
okay you're in the hallway are you down
to go to the bed and you're like okay
well there's a lot of room in the bed
exactly what I was thinking before I
walked in the room and I own [ __ ] God
y'all can slap me right now for this
[ __ ] but this is my message on to the
women don't I'm stupid don't he is not
your friend band members are not your
friend but my thought was I bet you it's
kind of gorgeous bathroom this is why
I'm terrified of having a girl for being
so smart we're stupid as [ __ ] it's
barely it will like pressure you to know
and Athiya is is that like I don't I
think that part of the reason I like I
kind of joke about it but like I think
part of the reason I even stepped in the
room is because he was so insistent and
I know my boundaries I knew that I knew
that I would not let something like that
happen to me so that's why I just wasn't
so much but there are some women that
are a little more demure that can't
stand up for themselves like that and
then there's guys like that that prey on
them so how does like happens the other
way - if I didn't really like a girl but
she started sucking my dick it's already
game over I don't know about that never
happened you know I'm just saying I just
never got in that situation I get it I
know so why doesn't that work if a guy's
using that same confidence just yelling
at you randomly like yobbos I'd you know
what though it sounds it sounds like
really dumb but like I've been I've been
cat called like know a lot before but a
few times I never get upset by it
because sometimes I have low self-esteem
days and I'm like okay cool I still got
it I'm just trying to take it as a
compliment cuz I'm not gonna see that
dude again and it is what it is but I
mean do you think it's partially
disbelief what y'all are going through
like in these situations like you're
kinda like nah that can't be happening
like there's a syndrome for that we're
like when people can they can walk past
the rape happening or a burglary or
whatever they're like nah that's
probably not what's happening catcalled
no no like in your specific situation
like you being treated like yeah yeah
because it sounds like something that
doesn't happen to me yeah it's like yeah
like I'm there's no way I'm a groupie in
this situation and I'm like a friend or
whatever yeah I didn't I I didn't think
of myself as a groupie at all but like
he and the other band members just
thought of me as a groupie that was here
to [ __ ] and like I just I I'm dumb you
know yeah boy and they treatments they
treat you like you're a cow like at the
pasture like it's like it's like hey
something wrong with this one like why
is it
Bachchu pizza all these guys out there
advance out there like this they're
letting the secret out they're not the
wolf no then it's like and then some
people at the other night they would
feel like this guy owed you know them
something I'm like you gave me two shots
and pizza and I was backstage like
really but he could have asked any one
pose but he asked do you so you oh oh my
god I think he's really not to me
dead-ass like we're Facebook friends I'm
sure I know Cal that night you know what
though he didn't delete me mmm I'm one
of many one of them the bigger man I
don't know so I think the difference is
because I don't know personally I've
never even gone on a date with someone
like a stranger that's asked me on a
date I have to like have a conversation
be mentally stimulated by them and then
be like like I kind of like this and I
will rather I would like to have another
conversation with this person and then I
would go on a date with them got it
whereas like someone random from the
street it's like they could look like
Brad Pitt and I'm not touching that they
could be a [ __ ] American psycho
serial killer yeah well some people are
more adventurous it's also like even
even not even catcalling but just like
hitting on somebody in a very public
setting or like when you don't know each
other at all then my head is like oh is
this how you normally pick up people
like I don't really like this so what if
we go on a date and I really like you
when we start dating and then you're
just out at the bar just be like
that's nice Morgan anything huh you
think that's good is that sexy does have
a man smell you like that have a man
smell you like he like you smelling
[ __ ] pine I would feel sexy could you
accepted when I lived in Hollywood
though like I definitely had cat calling
people all the time and I would always
thank them oh like that they'd be like
yo your ass is fine I'd be like thank
you so much I've been doing lots of
squats
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]